good morning Hank it's Tuesday today's
video is like nothing you ever bought at
IKEA it comes to you in only two parts
part 1 commencing so over the weekend
Sara and I drove to Gambier Ohio where I
got to deliver the commencement address
at my alma mater Kenyon College here's
part of what I said so when I was a
student here there was widespread
agreement among my peers that the
so-called real world of proper adulthood
was basically a disease you caught and
then eventually died from like adulthood
with it's mortgages and spreadsheets and
lawn maintenance seemed to be a thing to
be dreaded and resisted until finally it
overtook you like a zombie plague and
then like once you acquired adulthood
you would start saying things like brand
awareness in a fractured media landscape
and we need a president who knows how to
get things done to be an adult meant
engaging in totally on Iran akan verse a
shion's about the weather I remember
once when I was at Kenyon my grandmother
called me to tell me that she was
watching The Weather Channel and that it
looked like it was raining in Ohio I
explained to her that I was reading
Ulysses that I wasn't even in Gambier
but in Dublin Ireland in 1904 and that
history was a nightmare from which
Daedalus was trying to awake and that
nothing literally nothing mattered less
than the current weather and then after
a moment she asked well is it raining or
isn't it to be an adult was to be a
river rock blasted by an endless torrent
of mundane terrors from resume
formatting to electricity bills
that would inevitably smooth all my hard
edges until I looked and felt just like
everything else now this is the part of
the commencement address where I am
supposed to tell you that in fact
adulthood isn't so bad and blah blah
blah but no no it is so bad sidenote
graduation gowns are not flattering in
the end the speech is mostly just a
celebration of
ironic conversations about the weather
if you want to watch or read the whole
thing you can do so links in the
dooblydoo part two sports so Hank I am
in the midst of the greatest sports
month of my life a couple weeks ago I
drove the pace car at the Indianapolis
Grand Prix which allowed me to
experience what it's like to be
tailgated by 30 professional racecar
drivers we're just six days away from
the annual highlight of my social
calendar the Indianapolis 500 and most
amazingly the fourth tier English
football team nerdfighteria sponsors AFC
Wimbledon have found themselves in the
playoff finals just one victory away
from being a third tier English football
team that's right Hank on May 30th AFC
Wimbledon will take the field at Wembley
a 90,000 seat stadium and wearing dftba
on the back of their shorts they will
play a one-game playoff against the
sailing ships of Plymouth Argyle it's
hard to describe how unlikely this is
Wimbledon have the smallest stadium of
any team in their league and among the
smallest budgets they'd also be the only
English team owned by their fans to be
as high as the third tier so this is a
massive moment for the club and as you
know if you listen to our podcast where
you can get all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon I am
immensely excited in fact tank I am
leaving directly from the Indianapolis
500 to go to the game in London so
nerdfighters if you live in or near
London I hope you will come to Wembley
on May 30th to cheer on the dons if you
want to go to the game but can't afford
to take it email me and I will try to
work something out info and all of that
in the doobly-doo Hank I know that
sports are silly but as pope john paul
ii once said of all the unimportant
things football is the most important
Hank I'll see you on Friday